This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一档I-Heart播客节目。保证全真人。嗨，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人克尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）为你带来的《难学之法》。这个节目旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本无法安全进行的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士一起探讨。有多少男人身披铠甲。这向全世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它，去倾听并学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《难学之法》。2023年，“单身汉”男星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾多次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探，才能揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是数字2%。在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。在Iheart radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜，相信我》。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. I'm so glad that you're here. I'm really excited for this episode because it is something that comes up so much on the podcast and is such a deeply hidden fear for so many of us. One of the things I hear so often from 20-somethings from people beyond that age, people in their 30s, is this fear of ending up alone and of never finding the one. I hear it from people who have never dated before and feel very inexperienced and behind when it comes to those romantic
大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里收听又一期节目，当然，我们要在这里剖析二十岁时的心理学。我很高兴你来到这里。我真的对这一期节目感到兴奋，因为这是播客中经常出现的一个话题，也是我们许多人内心深处隐藏极深的恐惧。我经常从二十几岁的人，以及比这个年纪更大、三十多岁的人那里听到的一件事，就是这种最终孤独终老、永远找不到真命天子的恐惧。我从那些从未约会过、在面对这些浪漫情境时感到非常没有经验、落后于人的人那里听到这种说法
situations and hitting those romantic milestones that everybody around them seems to have already met and, you know, they find it really hard to imagine that they'll find love because they've never experienced it before. I also hear from people who have been in long-term relationships for years and years, and they've broken up with their partners, perhaps the person that they thought they were going to marry, and they wonder, they wonder that they've missed their chance to grow old with somebody and whether they will ever find anyone better. It is such a common dilemma, one that I think really unites us not just as 20-somethings, but But as people, as human beings, I don't want to be alone.
他们似乎已经达到了所有人似乎都已经达到的那些浪漫里程碑，你知道，他们发现自己很难想象能找到真爱，因为他们从未经历过。我也从那些长期处于恋爱关系中多年、并与伴侣分手的人那里听到这种说法，也许这个人就是他们原本以为要结婚的人，他们在想，他们在想自己是否错过了与某人一起变老的机遇，以及他们是否还能找到比这更好的人。这是一个非常普遍的困惑，我认为它不仅作为二十几岁的人，而且作为人类、作为个体，真正地将我们联系在了一起，我不想孤单。
I want love. I want someone to share my life with. And it's not bad to admit that or to assume that just because you have this deep desire to maybe eventually find somebody. You can't also be happy as a single person. You can be so self-aware and content and fulfilled and still want someone to add to your life without giving up everything that makes you independent already. But I also think in many ways we have been conditioned to see singlehood as this curse,
我想要爱。我想要有人与我分享生活。承认这一点并没有错，或者仅仅因为你内心深处有着最终找到某个人的强烈渴望，就认为你不能作为一个单人同样过得幸福，这也是不对的。你可以非常具有自我觉察、心满意足且感到充实，同时仍然希望有个人来丰富你的生活，而无需放弃所有已经让你保持独立的东西。但我也认为，在许多方面，我们已经被条件反射般地将单身视为一种诅咒，
as something that everybody wants to avoid. And that really fosters a fear of being alone and a fear of ending up alone. When really I don't think that that's the worst thing that could happen to us. This episode was really inspired by someone who contributed to our 20-something diary series on Instagram, if you follow us on Instagram, you will know that once a week, we basically talk to someone anonymously who is in their 20s, somewhere in the world, and we ask them, what are you worried about? How much do you have in savings? What do you want to change in the next five years? And we have this person from Perth and Australia right in and talk about how the thing
将其视为每个人都想避免的事情。这确实助长了对孤独的恐惧以及对最终孤老终的恐惧。而实际上，我认为这并非可能发生在我们身上的最糟糕的事情。这一期节目的灵感确实来自于一位为我们在Instagram上的“二十岁日记”系列做出贡献的听众，如果你关注了我们的Instagram，你就会知道，一周一次，我们会与世界某地一个二十多岁的匿名人士交流，我们问他们，你在担心什么？你的存款有多少？你在接下来的五年里想改变什么？我们有来自澳大利亚珀斯的一位听众写信谈到，她最担心的事情
that she is most worried about is ending up alone. And during this like day in a life that she gave us, she was going on a date and she kind of spoke about how she was in this relationship for most of her late 10 years and early 20s, suddenly found herself single and had been single much longer than she expected. And with each passing year, it just felt like more and more people were finding the one, we're getting into these relationships and there were no good people left. There was nobody left that would fulfill her or be her partner. And it just kind of felt like a race, like a race to find someone before she turned 30. And when I posted that and we spoke about it, so many of you could relate. So many of you were listening and reading her account
就是最终孤独终老。在她给我们描述的日常生活中，她正要去约会，她谈到自己如何在十几岁后期和二十岁初期的绝大部分时间里都处于恋爱关系中，突然发现自己单身了，而且单身的时间比她预期的要长得多。随着时间的推移，她感觉好像越来越多的人找到了真命天子，走入了这些关系中，而剩下的全都是不优秀的人。没有人能满足她或成为她的伴侣。这感觉就像是一场比赛，一场在30岁之前找到某人的比赛。当我发布了这个内容并讨论它时，你们中有很多人都感同身受。你们中有很多人在听着并阅读她对
of situation ship after situation ship with no future and no exclusivity and really seeing yourself reflected back at you. I think at the root of what this person was talking about, what we're talking about today is a completely natural fear of loneliness, a fear of missing out, a fear of falling behind, a fear of judgment of uncertainty, like, you know, who am I going to have when I'm old and gray? And of course, social pressure and how so many of the cultural narratives we experience and we're exposed to seem to innately tie our self-worth and our identity to a relationship status. Like, having a partner, you know, finally means that you are desired. and valuable. And if you don't have a partner, that is a personal failure, there is something
一段又一段没有未来、没有排他性的“situationship”（暧昧关系），并真正看到了自己的影子。我认为这个人所谈论的核心、我们今天所讨论的核心，是对孤独的一种完全自然的恐惧，对错失事物的恐惧，对落后的恐惧，对评判和不确定性的恐惧，比如，你知道的，当我老态龙钟时，我身边会有谁？当然，还有社会压力，以及我们所经历和接触的许多文化叙事，似乎是如何本能地将我们的自我价值和身份与恋爱状态联系在一起的。比如，拥有一个伴侣，你知道的，最终意味着你是有吸引力的、是有价值的。如果你没有伴侣，那就是个人失败，你身上有某种
about you that is lacking. It is such a labyrinth. I don't feel like I don't need to tell you that if you're experiencing it right now. And it can be pretty emotionally draining when you've been dating with no luck, no end in sight, when you want to deprioritize dating and actually be happy alone, but it feels like there is this little voice in your head being like, you're running out of time, you're running out of time. So today, let us talk about it. We're going to talk about this very innate and psychological fear of ending up alone, where it comes from, what kind of people it turns us into, how it influences our dating habits as well, and how it is possible for us to really hold two truths at once. I want love, but love is not my only purpose. I can be happy alone and still want a
有所欠缺的东西。这真是一个迷宫。如果你现在正经历这一切，我觉得我不需要向你说明。当你一直在约会却毫无运气、看不到尽头时，当你想把约会的事放在次要位置、真正享受独处却感觉脑海里有个小声音在说“你的时间不多了，你的时间不多了”时，这会在情感上相当消耗。所以今天，让我们来谈谈它。我们要谈谈这种非常本能且心理上的恐惧——最终孤老终，它从何而来，它把我们变成什么样的人，它又如何影响我们的约会习惯，以及我们如何能够真正同时抱持两种真理。我想要爱，但爱并非我唯一的目的。我可以享受独处，却依然想要一段
relationship without letting it sabotage my individuality. How exactly do we sit with our fear, without letting it control us or making us very deeply unhappy and stressed as it so often does. Well, strap in, we have so much to unpack, so much to talk about today. And surprisingly, perhaps not surprisingly, if you were a long-term listener, a whole lot of science and psychology to explain what it is you may be feeling. So without further ado, let's get into it. Our fear of being alone is a lot more complex than just that, just simply being alone.
伴侣关系，同时不让它破坏我的独立性。我们究竟该如何正视这种恐惧，而不让它控制我们，或者像它经常做的那样，让我们陷入深深的不幸和压力之中？好吧，系好安全带，我们要剖析的内容太多了，今天要谈的太多了。而且令人惊讶的是，如果你是一个长期听众，这或许并不令人意外，这里有大量的科学和心理学来解释你可能正在感受的东西。闲话少说，让我们切入正题。我们对孤独的恐惧要比单纯的孤独复杂得多。
It really taps into our very core, and I would say primal, fears of firstly rejection, and secondly, isolation. Two things that we have been hardwired for millions of years. Millions of years of evolution have taught us to avoid those two specific feelings and experiences. As humans, we really thrive on being seen, being loved, being surrounded by community. and it has built us to really want connection wherever we can find it, and to build trust, build something bigger that feels meaningful and safe around those connections. That is what ensured our survival long, long ago.
它真正触及了我们的核心，我可以说，是人类最初的恐惧：首先是遭到拒绝，其次是感到孤立。这是我们在数百万年的进化中被硬编码（hardwired）的两件事。数百万年的进化教会了我们去避开这两种特定的感觉和体验。作为人类，我们真正依靠的是被看见、被爱、被社区所包围，它让我们天生就想要在能找到的任何地方建立连接，并围绕这些连接建立信任，构建某种更大、感觉有意义且安全的东西。正是这一点确保了我们在很久很久以前得以生存。
When we don't have that, especially when it comes to a romantic love and we've been single for some time or we've never dated, when we've maybe been rejected far too many times and we would like to acknowledge, this elicits a very distinct kind of feeling known as social pain. So social pain occurs when we feel isolated, we feel excluded, rejected, cut off. And it may sound like it's less serious than physical pain, but actually neuroscientists back in 2014 in Italy found that when they were studying the brain regions that lit up when we were experiencing rejection versus physical pain, it was the exact same region that was processing those distinct kinds of discomfort and pain. So this area, this brain region
当我们没有这些时，尤其是当我们渴望浪漫的爱情却已经单身了一段时间，或者从未约会过，当我们遭受的拒绝可能比我们愿意承认的要多得多时，这会引发一种非常独特的感觉，被称为社会痛（social pain）。所以，当我们感到孤立、被排斥、被拒绝、被切断联系时，就会产生社会痛。这听起来可能没有身体痛那么严重，但实际上，早在2014年，意大利的神经科学家在研究我们经历拒绝与经历身体痛时大脑中被点亮的区域时发现，处理这两种不同类型的痛苦和不适的区域完全是同一个。所以这个区域，这个大脑区域
is called the posterior insular cortex, for those of you interested. And that is what we used to think as our pain receptor. And our pain receptor in terms of, you know, we kick our foot or like bump our toe or we cut our finger and that's where physical pain is processed and that is the only role of that area. Here is a brief lesson about pain though. Pain, pain. is constructed entirely by our brain and by our neurons that are responding to some environmental stimuli or cue. You know, if you bump your knee, you'll be like, yeah, my knee hurts, but it's actually your brain that is creating that painful experience for you. And the same goes for social pain. And that social pain, when we get rejected, when we feel lost, lonely, when we feel
被称为后岛叶皮层（posterior insular cortex），供感兴趣的朋友参考。这就是我们过去认为是疼痛感受器的地方。我们认为的疼痛感受器是指，比如我们踢到脚或者撞到脚趾或者割破手指，身体痛就是在这里处理的，而这也就是该区域的唯一作用。不过，这里有一个关于疼痛的简短课程。疼痛，疼痛完全是由我们的大脑以及对某些环境刺激或线索做出反应的神经元构建的。你知道，如果你撞到膝盖，你会说，是的，我的膝盖很疼，但实际上是你的大脑在为你创造那种痛苦的体验。社会痛也是如此。这种社会痛，当我们遭到拒绝，当我们感到迷失、孤独、当我们觉得自己
unworthy of love is happening in that same cortex area, the posterior insular cortex. If you have been, you know, single for some time and you recently went on yet another date that was a dud or you feel disconnected from all your friends who are in relationships who just aren't making the time for you that they used to, that is a painful experience and it is felt as intensely as physical pain. It is processed, created, constructed, felt by the exact same region. So I really don't want you to be sitting there being like, oh my God, I'm just making way too much of this situation. I don't want you to be shaming yourself for this experience, feeling like you're overreacting, feeling like it's not as intense as you feel it is, because the science is telling us, the, you know,
不配得到爱时，就发生在同一个皮层区域，即后岛叶皮层。如果你一直，你知道的，单身了一段时间，而你最近又去了一次毫无进展的约会，或者你感到自己与所有处于恋爱关系中却不再为你腾出时间的朋辈疏远了，那是一种痛苦的体验，它的感受和身体痛一样强烈。它是由完全相同的区域处理、创造、构建和感受的。所以我真的不希望你坐在那里想，天哪，我对这种情况小题大做了。我不希望你因为这种经历而感到羞愧，觉得反应过度，觉得它没有你感觉的那么强烈，因为科学告诉我们，
research is telling us that actually, no, it is very equal to what might be a much more valid physical experience of pain or what society would like to tell us as a valid painful experience. So we have a natural drive to want to find someone. We are both motivated by the comfort of finding someone and the discomfort of the social pain that we tend to experience. We are hardwired to avoid these scary feelings of isolation and rejection. However, the thing is, is that so often just because we are single, we aren't actually fully alone.
研究告诉我们，实际上，并非如此，它与那种更具正当性的身体痛苦体验，或者社会想要告诉我们的正当痛苦体验完全平分秋色。因此，我们有一种寻找伴侣的自然驱动力。我们既受到找到某人的慰藉的驱动，也受到我们倾向于体验的社会痛的不适感的驱动。我们的基因决定了我们要避开孤立和拒绝带来的这些可怕感觉。然而，问题在于，很多时候，仅仅因为我们是单身，并不意味着我们真的完全孤独。
We are surrounded by people. We're surrounded by friends and family. family, we do have community. So it's interesting because surely this experience of isolation shouldn't sting as much as we think. It's not like we're stranded in like the wilderness and a boyfriend or a girlfriend would be our only chance for connection. We actually have plenty of chances for connection. It's interesting because what we are lacking is not an entire support system. We are just lacking a mate or a partner. And why is it that despite having all of those connections, we still feel this social pain so intensely.
我们被人群包围。我们被朋友和家人包围，我们确实有社群。所以这很有趣，因为这种孤立的体验理应不该像我们想象的那样刺痛。这不像是我们被困在荒野中，而一个男朋友或女朋友将是我们建立连接的唯一机会。我们其实有很多建立连接的机会。这很有趣，因为我们所缺乏的不是整个支持系统。我们只是缺少一个伴侣或另一半。为什么尽管拥有所有这些连接，我们仍然如此强烈地感受到这种社会痛？
If you want to identify why people fear and feel this fear so intensely, even when they have, you know, platonic and familial relationships around them, you have to also examine the cultural environment that we are in. It is very hard to feel shame or embarrassment or even fear about something. If somebody hasn't told you in the first place that there is something wrong with what you are doing, or that there is something wrong with your reality, or someone hasn't scared you with some awful future hypothetical of being miserable and regretful and lonely at 50. Our fear of being alone is also partially derived from our environment.
如果你想找出为什么人们会有如此强烈的恐惧感，即使他们身边有柏拉图式的和家庭关系，你也必须审视我们所处的文化环境。如果有人一开始没有告诉你你的做法有什么不对，或者你的现实有什么不对，或者没有用那种在50岁时悲惨、后悔和孤独的可怕未来假设来吓唬你，你很难对某事感到羞耻、尴尬甚至恐惧。我们对孤独的恐惧部分也源于我们的环境。
I would say about 20% of it might be biology and evolution. The rest of it, the 80% that is left over is societal, it is cultural, it is social. If you are single right now, I feel like I don't even need to tell you this, but society really does prioritize partnership and it puts romanticly. love on a pedestal. A relationship is like this golden prize and it's made to seem so wonderful. People write poetry and love songs and create works of art about love. They spend hundreds of thousands of dollars to show their love for one another through a wedding and lavish gifts and huge grand gestures. You know, people die for love. People survive for love. That looks pretty appealing.
我想其中大约20%可能归结于生物学和进化。剩下的80%则是社会的、文化的、环境的。如果你现在单身，我觉得我甚至不需要告诉你这一点，但社会确实优先考虑伴侣关系，并将浪漫爱情奉上神坛。恋爱关系就像是这个金色的奖品，被描绘得如此美好。人们为爱写诗、写情歌、创作艺术品。他们花费成百上千美元，通过婚礼、奢华的礼物和巨大的宏大姿态来表达对彼此的爱。你知道，人们为爱而死。人们为爱而生存。这看起来相当吸引人。
And if you've never experienced it before or it's something that you're really longing for, that can be made to seem a lot bigger than it actually is. Society is also not fully accepted the timeline that is becoming more and more common in which people stay single for much longer, or they adopt the kind of life in which, you know, you can be happy alone. There is still this overarching philosophy of, you know, who are you if you are not in love? Who are you if you are not in a relationship?
如果你从未经历过，或者这正是你真正渴望的，它就会显得比实际情况更加宏大。社会也还没有完全接受这种日益普遍的时间线，即人们单身的时间要长得多，或者他们采纳了那种你可以独自过得幸福的生活方式。依然存在着这样一种总体哲学，你知道，如果你没有恋爱，你算什么？如果你没有处于恋爱关系中，你算什么？
You are still half a person. And it's that kind of culture of, of shaming and of stereotypes and perhaps of stigma, that plays on our more evolutionary fear of isolation. Where this has seen a lot and felt a lot is around things like language. You know, there are words like spinster and cat lady. That's definitely one dimension. But it even goes deeper than that.
你仍然只是半个人。正是这种羞辱、刻板印象以及也许是耻辱的文化，在我们的进化恐惧（即对孤立的恐惧）上火上浇油。这在很大程度上被看到和感受到的地方是语言之类的事情。你知道，有诸如老处女（spinster）和猫女（cat lady）之类的词。这绝对是一个维度。但它甚至比这更深入。
So there's this data from a survey that was conducted by the dating service match back in 2019. and it showed that 52% of single people that they surveyed in the UK had experienced single shaming in conversations and in the language that was used to approach their relationship status. And so when researchers kind of dug into this and they were like, what do you mean by language, they talked about these shaming phrases. A lot of people,
约会服务机构match在2019年进行的一项调查数据表明，他们在英国调查的单身人士中，有52%的人在谈话以及处理他们恋爱状态的语言中经历过单身羞辱。因此，当研究人员深入研究这一点并问“你们所说的语言是什么意思”时，他们谈到了这些羞辱性的短语。很多人，
a lot of these single people had heard things like, you'll find someone better soon, 29% said they'd heard or had experienced. people suggesting that they must be really lonely. 38% of them just reported a general level of pity in conversations over their relationship status. And this led to many of them to report having an increased sense of urgency, even panic, to find someone when actually about 55% of them were pretty happy with their relationship
许多单身人士都听到过这样的话：“你很快就会找到更好的人”，29%的人表示他们听过或经历过别人暗示他们一定真的很寂寞。其中38%的人报告说，在谈论他们的恋爱状态时，存在一种普遍的同情情绪。这导致他们中的许多人报告说，当实际上他们中大约55%的人对自己的恋爱状态相当满意时，他们却产生了一种增加的紧迫感甚至恐慌感，急于去找到某人。
status. And they were pretty happy with it until an outside force came in and disturbed that piece. this language, you know, these shaming phrases of you'll find someone soon, you must be so lonely, are you dating at the moment, or you're not, that's such a shame. It implicitly assumes that everybody's goal is to find love. And the fact that you haven't assumes that something is wrong with you. Either A, you must be lonely or defective, which is not true. You know, most research shows that single people actually have equal.
他们对此相当满意，直到外部力量介入并打破了这份平静。这种语言，你知道，这些羞辱性的短语，如“你很快就会找到人”、“你一定很孤独”、“你现在在约会吗，还是没有，那太遗憾了”，默认了一个假设，即每个人的目标都是找到真爱。而你还没有找到这一事实，则假设你出了什么问题。要么A，你一定很孤独或者有缺陷，这并非事实。你知道，大多数研究表明，单身人士实际上拥有与非单身人士同样丰富和充实的生活，或者他们假设你无法承诺，你的基因不对路，你的基因使你排斥伴侣关系。
rich and fulfilled lives as non-single people, or they assume that you are unable to commit, that you were wired the wrong way, you were wired away from partnership. And for men, they're perhaps given a bit more of a free pass when it comes to that to be uncommitted and to be running around. For women, not so much. And again, it's not true that you are unable to commit or that you have some kind of abandonment problem or whatever it is. It's more likely that you're just not willing to commit to the wrong person.
至于男性，在不承诺和到处玩耍方面，他们也许会被给予更多的宽容。对于女性来说，则并非如此。同样，你无法承诺或者你有某种放弃问题之类的事情也是不真实的。更有可能是你只是不愿意对错误的人做出承诺，
and that should be totally normalized. But because it is always about partnership before you as a person, there is still a level of shame. And these false beliefs around who you must be if you're not prioritizing dating and a relationship in your 20s or just in your life in general. All in all, I think these assumptions, this language, it displays the lives of single people as being less rich.
而这应该被完全正常化。但因为焦点总是放在作为一个人的你之前的伴侣关系上，所以仍然存在一定程度的羞耻感。这些围绕着如果你在二十几岁或整个人生中没有把约会和恋爱放在首位，你一定是个什么样的人的错误信念。总而言之，我认为这些假设、这些语言，将单身人士的生活描绘成不够丰富的生活。
And I am like a huge fan of a lot of accounts and Instagram accounts that are put. pushing down the stereotype. But even if you truly believe in the sacred nature and the benefits of being single, even if you are really, really happy where you are right now, I think the older we get, it's also natural for a bit more fear to creep in. And sometimes this comes down to yet another factor, which is social comparison. And even deeper than that, the fear of missing out on what everybody else seems to be having and seems to be enjoying. I think this is especially the case when you haven't dated or been in love before, seeing how much people really enjoy the experience,
我是许多账户和Instagram账户的超级粉丝，它们正在打破这种刻板印象。但即使你真心相信单身的神圣本质和好处，即使你对现在所处的位置真的非常非常满意，我认为随着我们年龄的增长，更多的恐惧潜入进来也是很自然的。有时这归结于另一个因素，那就是社会比较。比这更深层的，是害怕错过其他人似乎都在拥有并享受的事物。我认为特别是当你从未约会过或从未恋爱过，看到人们多么真正享受这种体验时，
or when you're kind of getting to a stage where people are moving in together, people are getting married, they're having kids, maybe you see a life that you may want at some stage. You see your friends kind of outgrowing, perhaps the life stage that you were all previously in, and it's really difficult and stressful, and the only way to describe it is a fear of missing out. It's also what psychologists may call a sense of ambiguous. loss. Feeling like you've lost something or you are grieving a life that you are yet to have, despite being really happy with the one that you do have. So because of these two conflicting truths, you know, I'm happy where I am, but I also feel a sense of, I don't know, desire or jealousy
或者当你正处于人们同居、结婚、生孩子的阶段时，也许你看到了你在某个阶段可能想要的生活。你看到你的朋友们超越了你们以前共同处于的生活阶段，这真的很困难、很有压力，唯一能形容它的词就是错失恐惧症（FOMO）。这也是心理学家所称的一种模棱两可的失落感（ambiguous loss）。感觉你失去了什么，或者你在为一个你尚未拥有、尽管对你确实拥有的生活非常满意的人生进行哀悼。因此，由于这两种相互冲突的真理，你知道，我对现状很满意，但我也感到某种欲望或嫉妒或恐慌感，
or a sense of panic. You are unable to really find a home or a place for these emotions. You feel constantly like there's a tug of war in your heart between staying, you know, staying single and doing what everyone around you is telling you to do. This creates dissonance. Basically, dissonance is just another word for being uncomfortable. And we don't like being uncomfortable. So we look for a way to lessen that discomfort. And often a relationship is the band-aid, right? It's a great way to do that. All our problems or our fears are solved. This isn't always for the best, though I feel like that is such an obvious statement, but let me just make it. What actually happens is that when we have this fixation, this focus on the life that will emerge
你无法真正为这些情绪找到一个安身立命之所。你不断地感到内心仿佛有一场拔河比赛，一边是保持单身，一边是做周围每个人都告诉你该做的事。这会产生认知失调。基本上，失调只是不舒服的另一个词。而我们不喜欢不舒服。所以我们寻找减轻这种不适的方法。通常，恋爱关系就是创可贴，对吧？这是一个很好的解决办法。我们所有的麻烦或恐惧都得到了解决。这并不总是最好的，尽管我觉得这是一个显而易见的陈述，但请允许我直言不讳。实际发生的是，当我们对这种生活产生这种执念和关注时——即如果我们单身太久就会出现的生活，
if we stay single for too long, we end up being ruled by fear. We end up being ruled by hypotheticals and catastrophizing that hasn't even happened yet, that may not even happen. when a fear or an anxiety towards this potential future is the only thing that we feel our behaviour becomes driven by that fear. And that behaviour is protective. It truly is. Because our brain, I guess, our higher conscious, our ego wants to protect our future self
我们最终会被恐惧所支配。我们最终会被假设和灾难化所支配，而这些甚至还没有发生，甚至可能根本不会发生。当对这种潜在未来的恐惧或焦虑成为我们唯一的感受时，我们的行为就会被这种恐惧所驱动。这种行为是具有防御性的。确实如此。因为我们的大脑，我猜，我们更高层次的意识、自我，想要保护我们未来的自己，
from what it sees as a harmful outcome. And a harmful outcome, you know, based on biology, based on this weird evolutionary drive, but also based on what society is telling you as the norm. this fear can firstly cause us to be less selective. So there was an article published about four years ago and the title is the predictive effects of fear of being single on physical attractiveness and less selective partner selection. Long title, I know, but look it up if you, if you want to, if you can. Basically what the researchers wanted to know is, okay, the more desperate you become, do you lower your standards? And I don't like the word desperate.
免受它视为有害结果的影响。有害的结果，你知道的，基于生物学，基于这种奇怪的进化驱动力，但也基于社会告诉你的常态。这种恐惧首先会导致我们的选择性降低。因此，大约四年前发表了一篇文章，标题是《对单联的恐惧对身体吸引力和选择性较差的伙伴选择的预测影响》。标题很长，我知道，但如果你愿意，如果你能做到，去查一下。基本上，研究人员想知道的是，好吧，你变得越绝望，你的标准会降低吗？我不喜欢绝望这个词，
I hate that word, but, you know, the more fearful of our future status is. as a single person, the more fearful of that we are, do we become less selective? I will take a direct quote from this paper because I think it really solidifies this point. For both men and women, a stronger fear of being single predicted greater romantic interest in dating prospects who were less responsive and less physically attractive. Once in a relationship, there was a lower likelihood of initiating breakups with dissatisfying partners. So what does that actually mean? It means that firstly, when we are really scared of being single and we are scared of that hypothetical above all else, we end up choosing people that
我讨厌这个词，但是，你知道的，我们对单身状态的未来越是感到恐惧，对这种恐惧越深，我们的选择性就会越低吗？我将直接引用这篇论文中的一句话，因为我认为它真正巩固了这一观点。对于男性和女性而言，对单身更强烈的恐惧预示着对反应较差、身体吸引力较低的约会对象的浪漫兴趣更高。一旦进入恋爱关系，与不满意伴侣分手的可能性就会降低。那么这到底意味着什么呢？这意味着，首先，当我们真的很害怕单身、最害怕那种假设时，我们最终会选择那些
firstly don't even like us back or who we don't even find attractive, but once we are in that relationship, even when we realize it's not for us, we stay because being with the wrong person is less scary than being alone. This can also mean that, you know, not only are less selective, we also undervalue ourselves. We undervalue what it is that we can bring to the table. And so we let people perhaps, and I don't like saying let, we perhaps experience circumstances where people are treating us not as well as they should. And they know that and we know that. because we kind of feel like we are forced to endure bad behavior or else encounter an even worse fear for ourselves and that is again the fear of being alone it also ties our self-esteem to our romantic or physical value
首先甚至不喜欢我们，或者我们甚至觉得没有吸引力的人，但一旦我们进入了这段关系，即使我们意识到它不适合我们，我们也会留下来，因为和错误的人在一起比独自一人不那么可怕。这也可能意味着，我们不仅选择性降低了，而且还低估了自己。我们低估了我们能带到桌面上来的东西。所以我们可能会让人们，我不喜欢说“让”，我们可能会经历这样一种情况：人们对我们的对待不如他们应该的那样好。他们知道这一点，我们也知道这一点。因为我们感觉自己仿佛被迫忍受糟糕的行为，否则就会面临更可怕的恐惧，也就是再次对孤独的恐惧。它还将我们的自尊与我们的浪漫或身体价值绑定在一起。
so what i mean by that is basically when we begin to perhaps buy into this belief that if you are alone that therefore says something about how attractive you are, how valuable you are, how desirable you are, how confident, how successful you are, the only way in your mind to make people not believe that about you, that you are unattractive, that you are undesirable, that you are not successful or not intelligent, is to find a partner. And when our self-esteem is tied to our relationship status, that is not a very sustainable bond. That is not a very sustainable relationship to maintain because it bobs up and down based on whether you are single or taken. And it means that everything about who we are, our authenticity, our confidence levels
我的意思是，基本上，当我们开始接受这种信念：如果你独自一人，这就说明了你的吸引力、你的价值、你的可欲性、你的自信、你的成功程度，那么在你心中让人们不再那样认为——认为你没有吸引力、不可欲、不成功或不聪明——的唯一方法就是找到一个伴侣。当我们的自尊与我们的恋爱状态绑定在一起时，那并不是一个非常可持续的纽带。那并不是一个很容易维持的可持续关系，因为它会根据你是单身还是恋爱中而上下起伏。这意味着关于我们是谁的一切、我们的真实性、我们的自信水平，
become tied to this very small part of our life, which is a label, which is an exclusive label. We also put a lot of pressure on everyone that we meet, even when they give us a whole lot of signs that they may not even be reciprocating what we're putting down. Perhaps we're kind of blind to it because we see a spark and we just chase it. And again, it's very much like an all-or-nothing approach. Like this relationship is what I need to be happy. It's what I need to feel good. It's what I need to impress other people. And it's what I need to finally feel maybe complete.
都与我们生活中这个非常小的部分（即一个标签，一个排他的标签）绑定在了一起。我们也对遇到的每个人施加了巨大的压力，即使他们发出了很多信号表明他们甚至没有回报我们的付出。也许我们有点视而不见，因为我们看到了火花就去追逐它。同样，这非常像是一种全或无的方法。就像这段关系是我快乐所需要的。这是我感觉良好所需要的。这是我给其他人留下深刻印象所需要的。也是我最终可能感到完整所需要的。
And I was speaking to a friend about this who was single for 26 years before she met someone. And I was asking her about it. I was like, you know, think back to that time when you were dating. What did it mean to you that status of being single for that long? Did it actually change how you approach situations? And she was like, yes, absolutely. She was like, everybody she met, everybody she encountered. She immediately ran this like series of series of series of,
我和一个朋友谈论过这件事，她在遇到某人之前单身了26年。我问过她这件事。我说，你知道，回想一下你约会的那段时期。单身那么长时间的状态对你意味着什么？它真的改变了你对待情况的方式吗？她说，是的，绝对改变了。她说，她遇到的每一个人，她接触的每一个人。她立即在脑海中进行了这样一系列的
situations in her head in which they could be the one. Her mind immediately went to the most far-off conclusions. Like, they would do one nice thing for her that meant that, you know, that was her husband, that was her future partner. Because, you know, it was just always on her mind. She was always thinking about it. She was always hoping for it in every situation, in every circumstance, and she didn't care who it was with. And what she was saying to me was that it was really frustrating because she kind of wanted her heart to slow down so her brain could catch up. And her brain could be rational without getting caught up in really intense feelings that ended up shutting down a lot of that logic.
情境模拟，他们可能是那个人。她的脑海立刻得出了最遥远的结论。比如，他们为她做了一件好事，就意味着，你知道，那是她的丈夫，那是她未来的伴侣。因为，你知道，这总是萦绕在她脑海里。她总是在想这件事。在每一种情况下，在每一种环境中，她总是对此抱有希望，而她不在乎对象是谁。她对我说的是，这真的很令人沮丧，因为她有点希望她的心跳能慢下来，这样她的大脑就能赶上。她的大脑可以保持理性，而不会陷入那些最终关闭了许多逻辑的强烈感觉中。
You know, she was like, oh, I would meet these people and we would literally go on one day. And there was nothing that you could say to convince me that they weren't the one. And so I began treating them like that before they'd even showed an interest in me. And she was like, I just kept getting my heart broken without ever actually being in anything serious, without ever even feeling like I'd done the relationship thing. So I think that really comes down to a sense of scarcity and a sense that we better like getting quick. We better find someone to commit to right now.
你知道，她说，哦，我会遇到这些人，我们字面意义上只约会了一天。没有什么话能说服我他们不是真命天子。于是我开始像对待真命天子那样对待他们，甚至在他们对表现出兴趣之前就这样做了。她说，我一直在不断地心碎，却从未真正经历过什么严肃的事情，甚至从未感觉自己做过谈恋爱这件事。所以我想这真的归结于一种稀缺感，以及一种认为我们最好赶快行动的感觉。我们最好现在就找个人承诺。
Otherwise, all the good ones are going to run out. Otherwise, we're going to, I don't know, somehow run out of time, somehow be left in the dust. And the scarcity effect really comes down to when something seems more rare to you, such as a relationship, you don't have one, that suddenly that thing that is scarce feels a lot more valuable because not everyone can have it, because you can't have it. It's basically like the grass is always greener mentality. It's, you know, wanting what you can't have. It's all of those things. It's looking at your situation and wanting the one thing that you're missing more than you even value the things that you do have. That can lead us to a pretty dangerous place, as I just described. And I
否则所有好的都被抢光了。否则我们就会，我不知道，不知怎的用光时间，不知怎的被甩在灰尘里。稀缺效应真正归结于当某事物对你来说显得更稀有时，比如一段恋爱关系，你没有，那么突然之间那件稀缺的东西感觉更有价值了，因为不是每个人都能拥有，因为你不能拥有。这基本上就像“草总是更绿”的心态。这就是，你知道，想要你无法拥有的东西。所有这些事情。看着你的情况，渴望你所缺少的唯一东西，甚至超过了你对你确实拥有的东西的珍惜。这可能会把我们带到一个相当危险的境地，正如我刚才所描述的。我
think when we encounter that kind of thinking, it's really important to remind yourself that it is much better to be single than to settle for something else. And blah, blah, blah, I get it. You probably heard that a million times. You know, that might not change the underlying desire or fear or behavior, but let's make it even more mathematic. You could settle down and spend the next five to 10 years in a mediocre relationship that eventually crumbles, meaning that you're going to be back to where you are now, back at the starting line, in 10 years time, or you could wait another three to five years, be selective and find the one. You could find the soulmate, you could spend the rest of your lives together, or you could have neither option and you could, yeah, maybe be alone for the rest of your
认为当我们遇到那种思维方式时，非常重要的是要提醒自己：单身比将就妥协要好得多。胡说八道，我懂。你可能已经听过一百万遍了。你知道，这可能不会改变潜在的欲望、恐惧或行为，但让我们把它变得更数学化一点。你可以安定下来，在一段最终崩溃的平庸关系中度过接下来的5到10年，这意味着10年后你将回到你现在所在的地方，回到起跑线上；或者你可以再等3到5年，有选择性地寻找真命天子。你可以找到灵魂伴侣，你们可以共度余生；或者你两种选择都没有，然后，是的，也许余生都独自一人，
life and maybe be really, really happy. Perhaps be the happiest version of yourself that you were ever going to be. The secret to living and fulfilling life is not as simple as a relationship status. I think that's the one thing that I really want us to remember. There is this weird fear that is implanted in us that we are on this timeline and this timeline involves securing a relationship and that if you don't have it, there's something wrong with you, your life isn't going to be as good. That is fearmongering. That is fear mongering that we eventually adopt ourselves because it's really hard not to.
也许真的非常非常快乐。也许成为你可能成为的最快乐版本的自己。过上充实生活的秘诀并不像恋爱状态那么简单。我认为这是我真的希望我们记住的一件事。有一种奇怪的恐惧植根于我们体内，即我们正处于一条时间线上，这条时间线涉及获得一段关系，如果你没有，你身上就有问题，你的生活就不会那么好。那是贩卖焦虑。那是我们最终自己接受的贩卖焦虑，因为很难不这样做。
So how do we really fully embrace our power, I guess, is I would like to. to say intentionally single people. How do we have patience? How do we also make our lives as rich as they possibly can before we get back out there, before we find someone who is going to match that? Well, I have some tips for you, some advice, and some psychology after this short break. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
那么，我们如何才能真正完全拥抱我们的力量，我想说，有意识的单身人士。我们如何保持耐心？在我们重新出发之前，在我们找到能与之相匹配的人之前，我们又如何让我们的生活尽可能丰富？好吧，在短暂的休息之后，我有一些建议、忠告和心理学知识要分享。所以请留步。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家等进行对话，
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
以看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题，都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
收听《2%》。也就是数字2%。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMAs上双击小肯姆（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush to do a little Kim. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
乔治·布什和小肯姆有什么关系。好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过这一关的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈80年代的“快克”（crack）可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我随时准备谈论快克，但只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看出有一条贯穿线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你完成那句话。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了，对于黑人来说。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
对我来说，这是美国历史上黑人群体最重要的年份之一。在 iHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts 或你听播客的任何地方收听回顾。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross.
有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此全身心地投入到追逐中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了胜负之争。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯。
Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person? because you're afraid. Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要。你是个好人吗？因为你害怕。因为这是两个不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹是因为想成为一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
加入我和科尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用。搜索 Learn the Hardway 并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that follow revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她说法中明显的不一致之处。这拉开了长达数年的法律诉讼战，旨在证明真相。你伪造了这个特定的检测两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. How can we still recognize that a relationship is part of our timeline? It's okay to want love. It's okay to desire that as part of your future, but not get bogged down by the fear of being alone and let it influence us to make rash decisions.
女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。我们该如何认识到，感情只是我们时间线的一部分？渴望爱情是没有错的。渴望将其作为你未来的一部分是没有错的，但不要被孤独的恐惧所吞噬，让它影响我们做出仓促的决定。
Because it's okay to say, like, yes, a big part of my life plan and something that I want for my future is to find someone and is to love them and build a family or a business or a house or a life, whatever it is. We just don't want that to be our goal. above everything else and feel like we can't start living till we've secured it. I think it's about pursuing an authentic, well-lived life that a relationship could only benefit but not complete. So my first tip around kind of countering this fear of being alone,
因为这样说是可以的，比如，是的，我人生规划中的一个重要部分，我对我未来的期望就是找到某人，去爱他们，建立一个家庭、一份事业、一个房子或一种生活，无论那是什么。我们只是不希望这成为压倒一切的目标。超越一切，让我们觉得在锁定它之前无法开始生活。我认为关键在于追求一种真实的、生活充实的生活，这种生活里有一段感情只是锦上添花，而不是全部。所以我的第一个建议，关于如何对抗这种对孤独的恐惧，
it revolves around continuing to make yourself an interesting person, find yourself interesting, find your life interesting, regardless of what's happening when it comes to your romantic life. And I think in this way, not only does it help us stay secure that we are a really cool person, this will come in time, but I think that authenticity in itself actually inevitably and eventually attracts the love that we want so badly, but in a healthy form and on its own timeline. Work on making yourself an interesting person and in the process, creating. a life that you absolutely fucking love that anyone who walks to the door is going to have to compete with. They are going to have to compete with your dream life before they are let in.
它围绕着不断让自己成为一个有趣的人，发现自己的趣味，发现你生活的趣味，无论你的感情生活发生了什么。我认为通过这种方式，它不仅能帮助我们确信自己是一个非常酷的人（这需要时间），而且我认为这种真实本身最终必然会吸引我们梦寐以求的爱情，但它是以一种健康的形式，并按它自己的时间表到来。致力于让自己成为一个有趣的人，在这个过程中，创造。一种你他妈绝对热爱的生活，任何走进这扇门的人都必须与之竞争。在他们被允许进入之前，他们必须与你的梦想生活竞争。
And that is a really hard bar to get over. And it means that you are more selective. It means that you also just enjoy your time as a single individual without seeing it as a waiting period without seeing it as like you being on the sidelines or you being on the bench before, you know, your life truly starts. That authentic well-lived life to me involves having things that keep you busy whilst giving you purpose, having things that make you feel aligned with yourself, actually exploring who you are. It is so, so rare that we have time in our life to actually think about what we want to think about what you want from yourself right now and from your future to think about your identity and who you really are. I really implore you to think about this.
这是一个极难逾越的门槛。这意味着你更有选择性。这也意味着你作为单身个体也能享受你的时间，而不把它视为等待期，不把它视为你在场边观望，或者你在替补席上，你知道，在你的生活真正开始之前。对我来说，那种真实、生活充实的生活包括拥有让你忙碌同时赋予你目标的事情，拥有让你感到与自己契合的事情，真正探索你是谁。我们在生活中极其极其难得有时间去真正思考我们想思考什么，思考你现在对自己和未来的期望，去思考你的身份和真正的你是谁。我真的恳求你考虑这一点。
When was the last time you really thought about those things? When was the last time you really thought about what kind of person do I want to be? What kind of life do I want to live? How am I going to work on myself? Am I really happy right now? I think that's one of the gifts about being single is that it does allow for that really intense and beneficial and significant self-focus. Another element of that authentic well-lived life also means having an active and engaged life, having hobbies and people you see in those spaces that casual social interaction that is such an antidote to the loneliness we sometimes feel and we're single. There's no shame around it.
你最后一次真正思考这些事情是什么时候？你最后一次真正思考我想成为什么样的人是什么时候？我想过什么样的生活？我要如何提升自己？我现在真的快乐吗？我认为这是单身带来的礼物之一，它确实允许这种非常强烈、有益且显著的自我关注。这种真实、生活充实的生活的另一个要素也意味着拥有一个积极和投入的生活，拥有爱好以及你在这些空间里见到的人，那种随意的社交互动正是我们有时感到孤独时的解药，当我们单身的时候。这没什么好羞耻的。
It is something that we experience. And also taking opportunities that you might only have while single. you know, being able to date freely and openly without looking for commitment, being able to drop what you're doing and go and explore and not having to, you know, really think about someone and really count them into your plans. That is something that we don't talk about when we get into a relationship, like it's another person to think about. And sometimes it's nice to just have to think about yourself. And also, like I said before, ensuring that when the time comes, when that, you know, someone does come into your life because no one goes through life without ever
这是我们都会经历的事情。并且还要抓住那些你可能只有在单身时才有的机会。你知道，能够自由、公开地约会而不寻求承诺，能够放下手头的事去探索，而不必（你知道）真正去考虑某个人并将他们算入你的计划中。这是我们在进入恋爱关系时不会谈论的事情，就像需要考虑另一个人一样。有时只需考虑自己感觉真好。而且，正如我之前所说，确保当时机到来时，当那个（你知道）某人确实进入你的生活时，因为没有人能一辈子都不
meeting somebody who could potentially really match them and be the person for them, knowing that you are going to still be in control of your fate. You are still the master of your own fate and you still get to be the one calling the shots around. Does this actually benefit my life? Am I being selective enough? Or does it feel like there is a hole that I couldn't feel myself? And that's why I'm pursuing this relationship. When we feel strong as an individual, we are able to bring that part of ourselves, bring that persona, bring that identity to dating in a way that is more selective,
遇到一个可能真正与他们般配并成为他们真命天子的人，你要知道你仍然在掌控自己的命运。你仍然是你自己命运的主宰，你仍然可以对以下问题做主：这真的对我的生活有益吗？我的选择性够吗？还是觉得心里有一个我自己填补不了的洞，所以我才在追求这段感情？当我们作为个体感到强大时，我们能够将自己的那部分、把那种人格、把那种身份带入约会中，这种方式更有选择性，
more mature. I also think more fruitful. And here's the added benefit. Authenticity makes you attractive. It makes you so much more attractive through its influence on our sense of self-confidence. If you know yourself and you know yourself well, you're not going to let the opinions of somebody else
更成熟。我也认为更有成果。这里还有一个额外的好处。真实让你有吸引力。通过它对我们自信心的影响，它让你变得更有吸引力。如果你了解自己并且对自我有深刻的认知，你就不会让别人的意见
or their approval or rejection of you get in the way of just being yourself. And you exude that kind of confident elixir that we are all after. If you want some evidence of this, you can check out a research paper that was published in 2015 by the Journal of Personality and Social Psychology. I have quoted this study so many times on the podcast because it is probably one of my favorites. But in this research, these researchers looked at a series of dating scenarios between two people in a lab,
或者他们对你的赞同或拒绝阻碍你做自己。你会散发出那种我们都在追求的自信灵药。如果你想寻找这方面的证据，你可以查阅2015年发表在《人格与社会心理学期刊》上的一篇研究论文。我在播客中引用过这项研究很多次，因为这可能是我最喜欢的之一。但在研究中，这些研究人员在实验室里观察了两个人之间的一系列约会场景，
and they found that confidence was actually one of the strongest predictors of romantic attractiveness. And confidence, we cannot have it without a sense of authenticity. One of the reasons that it's so attractive is that a lot of the things we want in a partner are really difficult to observe upon first meeting them, right? things like competence, things like drive, things like kindness, things like intelligence, you know, you only really get kind of a peek at whether somebody has all those things upon a first impression. But if that person shows up and is confident, we kind of believe that they know themselves, right? We believe that they have a reason for being confident and that this reflects
他们发现自信实际上是浪漫吸引力的最强预测因素之一。而自信，如果没有一种真实感，我们是不可能拥有的。它之所以如此有吸引力的原因之一是，我们在伴侣身上想要的很多东西在初次见面时真的很难观察到，对吧？像能力、上进心、善良、智慧这些东西，你知道，你只有在第一印象时才能对某人是否具备所有这些东西有个大致的了解。但如果那个人表现得很自信，我们就会觉得他们了解自己，对吧？我们相信他们有自信的理由，这反映了
their actual value as a partner. So we feel, you know, really into them. Another explanation, confidence creates a real aura that draws people in. I'm sure you've had that experience where you've met somebody, perhaps not even somebody that you're like romantically into, just like someone and you've just been like, wow, I want to be around you. You make me feel warm. You make me feel seen. You are like this bright light. And I think what that comes down to is that a lot of us do lack self-esteem. And so we are really intrigued by people who seemingly don't. We want to learn from these people. we want to maybe have that energy rub off on them. And if you take time to really build that in yourself,
他们作为伴侣的实际价值。所以我们对他们（你知道）真的很感兴趣。另一个解释是，自信创造了一种真正能吸引人的气场。我确信你也有过这样的经历，你遇到某人，也许甚至不是那种你在浪漫上感兴趣的人，只是某人，然后你就会觉得，哇，我想和你在一起。你让我感到温暖。你让我觉得自己被看见了。你就像这道明亮的光。我认为归根结底是因为我们很多人确实缺乏自尊。所以我们对那些看似不缺自尊的人真的很感兴趣。我们想向这些人学习，
I think it's just a win-win scenario. You attract better people and you're more discerning of those people as well. Another, I think, benefit of choosing to be very authentically aligned with yourself in a way that is not reliant on your relationship status is that it helps you disperse a lot of those false beliefs that society would have us believe about single people. And as we said before, it's those false. beliefs that contribute to this fear of being alone. If I'm single, you know, I must be unattractive. I must be boring. I must be unworthy. I must be lonely. That is what so much of the information
我们可能想从他们身上沾染那种能量。如果你花时间真正在自己身上建立这一点，我认为这绝对是一个双赢的局面。你会吸引更好的人，而且你对这些人的眼光也会更加挑剔。我认为，选择以一种不依赖恋爱状态的方式与真实的自我保持一致的另一个好处是，它能帮你消除社会强加给单身人士的许多虚假观念。正如我们之前所说，正是这些虚假信念导致了这种对孤独的恐惧。如果我是单身，你知道，我一定是没有吸引力的。我一定是很无趣的。我一定是不值得被爱的。我一定是很孤独的。这就是社会传递给我们的海量信息
we're picking up from society would lead you to believe. And that is what makes us feel like a partner is the only answer to making ourselves feel more worthy and being a full, complete person. You could trust that narrative. You could trust that societal rhetoric and that societal vision, or you could trust your own reality, which is that you are thriving, you are purposeful, you are busy, and you know yourself better than most people ever will. When you are confident in yourself, you are able to look at those beliefs that might be creating fear within you and creating poor decision making and say, actually, I don't think that that's true because I know myself better, than what this outdated narrative is trying to tell me.
会让你相信的事情。这就是为什么我们觉得伴侣是让自己感觉更有价值、成为一个完整之人的唯一答案。你可以相信那种叙事。你可以相信那种社会的辞令与愿景，或者你可以相信你自己的现实，那就是你正在蓬勃发展，你是有目标的，你是忙碌的，而且你比大多数人更了解自己。当你对自己充满自信时，你就能审视那些可能在你心中制造恐惧并导致糟糕决策的信念，并说，事实上，我认为那不是真的，因为我比这个过时的叙事试图告诉我的更了解自己。
The thing that really helped me when I was single was looking at people who were still single at 30 or 40 or 60 and had really vibrant lives because I feel like the examples we are so often given of happiness as we age is the happiness that we get from big milestones that are associated with a partner. You know, marriage, moving in together, having children together,
当我单身时，真正对我有所帮助的是观察那些到了30岁、40岁或60岁依然单身且拥有真正充满活力的生活的人，因为我觉得我们常常被赋予的关于随年龄增长而来的幸福的例子，都是从与伴侣相关的巨大里程碑中获得的幸福。你知道，结婚、同居、一起生孩子，
vacations together. Like it feels like past 35, a lot of the significant moments in our life need to be with somebody else. And when we counteract that with the examples of people who are still showing us that they are fulfilled and happy despite going against the blueprint, we are able to really, I think, dispose of that belief system and dispose of that construct. Somebody that I always used to think of was Emma Watson. And she did an interview a few years ago where she, like, publicly described herself as self-partnered.
一起度假。感觉就像过了35岁，我们生命中的许多重要时刻都需要和别人在一起。当我们用那些尽管违背常规但依然向我们展示他们过得很满足和快乐的人的例子来反驳这一点时，我们就能真正地，我认为，抛弃那种信仰体系和这种建构。我曾经经常想到的人是艾玛·沃森。几年前她接受过一次采访，在采访中她公开将自己描述为“自我伴侣”（self-partnered）。
That is a concept that I love. It's like, I'm not single. I'm self-partner. I'm like consciously dating myself. And she really, like, encouraged other people to view their own, I don't want to say lack of a romantic partner, but their singlehood as a positive, not a negative. Nearly like 40% of adults in the US don't have a partner. About half of those people. even express that they won't even interested in dating according to this research by the Pew
这是一个我非常喜欢的概念。就像，我不是单身。我是自我伴侣。我就像是有意识地和自己约会。她真的（比如）鼓励其他人将他们自己的（我不想说是缺少浪漫伴侣，而是）单身状态视为一种积极的事情，而不是消极的。根据皮尤研究中心的这项研究，美国近40%的成年人没有伴侣。大约一半的人
Research Centre. And I think that that is something that if you only listen to what the media said, if you only saw examples online or in movies or in the news or in like opinion pieces, you would believe that that is not the case. You would believe that it's the opposite, that most people are in relationships. Most people are happier in relationships. But in this example that they gave in this research, they talk about this woman, Bella DePollo. She is a famously single person. She's 69 years old. She's never been in a relationship.
甚至表示他们对约会根本不感兴趣。我认为如果你只听媒体怎么说，如果你只在网上、电影里、新闻里或评论文章里看到这样的例子，你就会相信事实并非如此。你会相信事实恰恰相反，大多数人都处于恋爱关系中。大多数人在恋爱关系中更快乐。但在这项研究中给出的例子里，他们谈到了一个名叫贝拉·德保罗的女人。她是一个著名的单身人士。她69岁了。她从未谈过恋爱。
And she describes her solo life as authentic, as fulfilling, as meaningful, as psychologically rich. That is the opposite of what the world would like to tell us about single people in order to fearmonger. And I think once again, those examples, wherever you see them in the world, they are really powerful because they get rid of the doom and gloom that fuels fear. Finally, I think it's so important that if you are somebody who is such a lover who really just want someone to pour all of that brightness and life and energy and passion and compassion into, remember that platonic love is just as important. Just having a partner is so lonely and I've seen that amongst people in my own life who
她将自己的独身生活描述为真实的、充实的、有意义的、心理上丰富的。这与世界为了制造恐惧而希望向我们灌输的关于单身人士的说法截然相反。我认为，再次说明，这些例子，无论你在世界的哪个角落看到它们，它们都非常强大，因为它们消除了助长恐惧的厄运和悲观情绪。最后，我认为非常重要的是，如果你是一个充满爱心的人，一个真正只想把所有的光芒、生命力、能量、激情和同情心倾注在某人身上的人，请记住，柏拉图式的爱（友情）同样重要。仅仅拥有一个伴侣是极其孤独的，我在我生活中的一些人身上看到了这一点，
deprioritized friendship once they had achieved that relationship status that they wanted. And they are very, very lonely people. Because as we said before, that social pain that we feel when we are isolated is real, it's tangible and it hurts. And so it's really important that if you are somebody who is a lover, is a giver, you find a way to still tap into that part of you either by showing that love to yourself or really fostering those connections that are going to sometimes last so much longer than a love connection than a romantic relationship.
一旦他们实现了想要的恋爱状态，就把友情放在了次要位置。他们是非常非常孤独的人。因为正如我们之前所说，当我们被孤立时感受到的那种社会痛感是真实的、切实的，而且是痛苦的。所以非常重要的是，如果你是一个充满爱心、乐于付出的人，你要找到一种方法来继续挖掘你身上的那一部分，要么通过向自己展示这种爱，要么真正培养那些有时能持续比爱情连接、比浪漫关系更久的连接。
Just because you are single, you are not alone. There are so many single people in their 20s. There are so many single people at any age. And it's not like every single one of them is miserable and hidden away and isolated. They have family, they have friends, they have people that they admire. I think our fear of being alone often occurs when we aren't given that vision of what life could be like as an unpartnered person. When there is a very shallow and false, false story about the unhappiness levels of people who are alone, of people who have never met the one. So finally, I want to wrap this up and just conclude by saying it's okay to want love.
仅仅因为你是单身的，并不意味着你孤单。二十多岁有那么多的单身人士。任何年龄都有那么多的单身人士。并不是他们中的每一个人都痛苦不堪、躲藏起来且与世隔绝。他们有家人，有朋友，有他们崇拜的人。我认为我们对孤独的恐惧往往发生在没有被赋予那种“作为一个无伴侣的人生活会是什么样”的愿景时。当关于独居者、那些从未遇到真命天子的人的不幸程度的故事非常肤浅且虚假时。所以最后，我想总结一下并以这句话结束：渴望爱是没有错的，
but don't let the pursuit of love dim you down. You are still young. You still have time. You will find the right person if that is what you are after. But don't wait for your life to start until then. The fear of being alone is a very, very deeply rooted one. It is an instinctual one. It is a primal one.
但不要让追求爱的过程黯淡了你的光芒。你还年轻。你还有时间。如果你追求的是这个，你会找到对的人。但不要在那之前把生活暂停。对孤独的恐惧是一种非常非常根深蒂固的恐惧。这是一种本能。这是一种原始的本能。
But it's also one that is stoked by a lot of unnecessary stories and pictures and narratives pushed by our society. So take your time. It's all right to just like really enjoy being self-partnered and exploring yourself. And if you fear being alone forever, just know that there are people who your worst fear is their reality. And I'm sure they would sit you down and say, it's really not that bad. I promise you it's not that bad.
但这也是一种被我们的社会所推崇的许多不必要的虚构故事、画面和叙事所煽动的恐惧。所以放慢脚步。真正享受做自己的伴侣并探索自我其实挺好的。如果你害怕永远孤独，只要知道有些人的最坏恐惧正是你的现实。我相信他们会让你坐下来对你说，真的没那么糟。我向你保证，真的没那么糟。
I promise you that there is a lot about this that was a choice that I made the same way that you will be able to make choices and you'll be able to. create a life that you want, regardless of whether dating right now feels out of your control, regardless of whether you feel very fixated on love right now. It is not the end of your life to not find love. So thank you so much for listening. This was a bit of a pep talk and I want to just extend a lot of empathy and a lot of strength and a lot of love to you for what you're going through. You do have time. I promise you. I'm not going to give you those like bullshit phrases of like it happens when you least expect it because I just don't think that is very helpful. And sometimes it's
我向你保证，这其中有很多是我做出的选择，就像你以后也能做出选择一样，你将能够创造你想要的生活，无论现在约会是否让你觉得无法掌控，无论你现在是否对爱情感到非常执着。找不到爱并不是你人生的终点。非常感谢你们的收听。这有点像是一次打气谈话，我想对你正在经历的一切表达大量的同情、力量和爱。你还有时间。我向你保证。我不会对你说那些诸如“当你不期待的时候它就会发生”的废话，因为我觉得那没什么帮助。有时它
not true. Sometimes it happens when you are like, when you most expect it because you are at your most authentic and at your most confident. And whilst you wait for that, build those things up. They are a tool. They are a skill. They are a part of you that never goes away that never expires, that can never be dimmed. So thank you so much for listening. If you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. Make sure you're following along or send this episode to a friend if you think that they would enjoy it. If you have any further thoughts, if you have an episode suggestion, I love hearing from you.
并不适用。有时它会在你（比如）最期待的时候发生，因为此时你处于最真实、最自信的状态。在你等待的那段时间里，培养这些品质。它们是一个工具。它们是一项技能。它们是你身上永远不会消失、永远不会过期、永远不会黯淡的一部分。非常感谢你们的收听。如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。确保你点击了关注，如果你认为某个朋友会喜欢这一集，请将它发送给他们。如果你有任何进一步的想法，或者有节目选题的建议，我很乐意听到你的反馈。
You can follow me at that psychology podcast or at Gemma Speg. Come and join the community. Come and say hi. And until next week, make sure that you are safe. You are kind. Above all else, you are gentle to you. yourself and we will talk soon. Hey, what's good, y'all?
你可以在 @thatpsychologypodcast 或 @gemmaspeg 关注我。快来加入这个社区吧。来打个招呼吧。直到下周，请确保你注意安全。你要善良。最重要的是，对自己温柔一点，我们很快会再聊。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit
你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实并不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着西装
are armored? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the I-Hard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
宛如身披铠甲？这向世界传递了一个信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去使用它。在 iHeart Radio、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，欧文斯女士，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，莱斯皮安。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
this is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在 iHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more
这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理坚韧度、健身以及在这个奇特的现代世界中培养韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是 TWO percent，在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我要成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝，在 iHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一档 iHeart 播客。真人保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击字幕中的任何句子即可发表评论。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他会得到应有的报应。我们总是说，要相信你的女性朋友。听女性朋友的话。相信我，宝贝，在 iHeart 广播应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。